-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from shows
like "Big Little Lies,"
"Parks and Recreation"
and "Severance."
He stars in the long-awaited
third season of "Party Down."
The season finale
premieres Friday on Starz.
Let's take a look.
-Okay, everybody. Great job.
-Yeah!
-Okay.
There is kettle corn
and Sprite in the courtyard.
-You guys got real Sprite?
-No, no.
We've got...
store brand!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Store brand! Yes!
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Adam Scott!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show!
-Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We consider you family
here on the show.
-Thank you very much.
-We've known you
for a long time.
And I was very happy
your actual family
was back in the green room.
I got to say hello to them.
-Thank you.
Yeah, they're here,
all three of them.
I was about to say four,
but there's only three of them.
-Yeah.
That would have
immediately made me think,
"Oh, you hired actors
to play your family."
-Yeah, and I can't
slip up like that.
I can't let that happen.
-And your kids are older
than mine.
You've got a -- what?
I guess a 10th grader
and an 8th grader.
-That's right. 16 and 14.
-And the 16 year old, driving?
-Driving a car.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he got his license
like a week and a half ago,
and it's terrifying.
But it's also kind of --
kind of great because now, like,
I'm here working in New York.
They live in Los Angeles,
so I have a GPS thing
so I can see him wherever he is.
I can even see what miles per
hour he's going at all times.
-Now, does he know that
you can track him like that?
-He's finding out right now.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Did you put a -- Did you, like,
put a tracker under the car?
-That's right.
Just like in "Breaking Bad."
I put the thing...
under the thing.
-You're like,
"I'm just going to do
an oil check, son."
-That's right.
"Let me see here."
But he, like, calls me.
He's like,
"I'm at 7-Eleven by myself."
And I'm like, "Yeah, I --
I know. I know exactly..."
Yeah. So it's scary,
but it's terrific for him.
-Did you teach him
how to drive?
-I did.
I and my wife taught him...
-Yeah.
-...together.
-I'm worried that my wife
thinks I'm such a bad driver
she's not going to let me teach
our kids how to drive.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Like she's going
to handle the entire thing?
-Yeah. She's already said, "Me
and my father will handle it."
-[ Chuckles ] Wow.
-Which is massively
emasculating.
-So your father-in-law
will step in.
-Yeah.
-That's terrible.
-That is terrible.
-Yeah.
-And then your --
What's your daughter into?
-She is primarily
right now into Taylor Swift.
-Okay.
-Right?
-I don't think
she's alone there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fine.
Like, I am -- Like, great.
That's a great thing.
-I will say of the music
a younger generation
can be into,
that is like so pleasant
and lovely.
-100%.
The thing that
she's into right now
is -- because her tour
is The Eras Tour.
[ Applause ]
And so you --
Everything you say
about Taylor Swift
gets a round of applause
at all times.
So you dress it --
When you go to that concert,
you dress up as whatever era
you're most into at the moment.
And so she's going to dress up,
I think,
for the Reputation era.
-Oh, so
your daughter
has chosen her era.
-Chosen her era,
at least for now.
-Do you have a Taylor Swift era
that you prefer?
-Yeah. I mean, I feel like
I would -- I would probably go
in the, like, Evermore era.
-Right.
I will say, of men our age,
that's the costume...
-Probably.
Because that's just a cardigan.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. That.
-And like a cup of tea.
-[ Laughs ] Right. Yeah.
-Which is what
we're already doing.
-Yeah. Yeah.
We're like -- People --
My kids will often walk in
when I'm drinking my tea
and they're like, "Is this
Eras?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yes!
-I'm in an era right now.
-I'm not just a dude
in a cardigan.
-No. That's not what I'm doing.
-"Party Down."
This is so exciting
because this is a show --
you could attest to --
nobody was watching this show
when it was on.
-No one.
-But then they found it
after the fact.
-Yeah, like seven years later.
-What?
How few people were
watching it when you...?
-We got canceled, rightly so,
in 2010.
Our series finale
had 13,000 viewers...
[ Laughter ]
...so
we should have been canceled,
as it turns out.
-And that's a
TV show anyone could watch
that did like less numbers
than a Taylor Swift show.
-That's exactly right.
-Like a concert.
-Oh, one concert would dwarf
our entire audience.
-You could run out
on stage and be like,
"Before you guys go, do you mind
watching an episode
of 'Party Down'?"
-And like 8,000 would leave.
-Was it a cool thing, though,
to find out...?
I mean, again,
it must have been disappointing
while you're making it
because it seemed like a show --
I have to believe
based on watching it --
it seems like
it's a blast to make.
-Yeah, it was super fun
and everything.
But, yeah, as we --
as the years went by,
people were kind of
catching on to it,
found its audience, and people
weren't even totally aware
it was an older show,
that it got canceled
like eight years ago
or whatever.
So they would come up and say
how much they loved the show
and when's the next season
coming on?
And it's like, "No, that's over.
Like, you can't --
It died.
It's the late, great
'Party Down.'
It's dead."
-Very nicely done.
-Yeah.
So, but now it is
actually back...
-And were you all just
collectively delighted
when this...?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It was so fun.
I mean, it's almost like reboots
are like a cliche now.
Everyone just says
how delighted
they are to be back
with all their friends, but
we were delighted to be
back with all of our friends.
Because we really --
like, it ended
and we were so deeply bummed.
But it also felt very
"Party Down" to be canceled.
It kind of fit in
with the ethos of the show.
-Right. Those characters...
If they were --
If those characters made a TV
show, it would definitely get
canceled.
-Yes. If we won in any way,
it just wouldn't feel right.
-I know you get approached
by fans all the time,
but I would imagine those
in the catering community
feel a great connection
to this show.
-They do.
-And you must be at events
where you interact
with caterers.
-Yeah, they -- Yeah.
You find that the caterers
and the bartenders
are mostly "Party Down" fans
and feel like
an immediate kinship,
which is great because
I get like my sliders first.
-Oh, wow. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's funny because you don't
get them for free
because they're already free.
-They're already free.
-But you get them first.
-And you don't want
them to zhuzh up your slider.
-Right, yeah.
-So just getting it
first ends up being the big win.
-That's pretty -- I mean...
-Listen.
-You're living it pretty good
right now.
-Show business is pretty great.
-[ Laughs ]
You know, I'm very excited.
I know you're out here.
You're filming the second season
of "Severance,"
a show we've talked about
that I just love.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks.
-Tonally...
Tonally, it couldn't be more
different than "Party Down."
But there is a similarity, which
it's you have a [bleep] job.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And I don't really like
doing it.
-Yeah, but you try really hard.
I mean, I think that's what --
you don't want
your colleagues to know
you think it's [bleep].
-That's right.
-You're the guy who's, like,
holding out, trying to rally the
troops.
-All of the effort
I put into the job
is put into making it look
like I don't hate it
or that I'm actually doing
something when I'm not.
That's where the two shows
share common ground.
-Well, it's nice that you have
that commonality.
-That's right.
-Another show that you did
with a great cast was
"Parks and Rec."
-Yeah,
-And there was a guy --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
Our next guest, Jeff Tweedy,
did a cameo on "Parks and Rec,"
and you look very happy to have
taken this photo with him.
-I was so, so happy that day,
that fine day
in 2000-whenever it was.
It was fantastic.
2014, probably.
-And he seems pretty psyched,
too.
So that's -- Must have been
a nice moment.
-I mean, it looks like he's --
I remember when we met,
he was like,
"Oh, my God, you're on the show.
This is cool. It's weird
seeing you in person."
And I was like,
"Are you [bleep] kidding me?
Really?"
And, yeah,
I was just delighted.
-Well, it's also --
You know, being as big a fan
as I am of him
and his band and you,
it's a very nice night
to have you all here together.
So thank you for being here,
my friend.
You guys, that's Adam Scott.
Third season finale of
"Party Down"
premieres Friday on Starz.